bonjour kader abderrahim merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
arte france question on l'a vu dans ce
sujet que reste-t-il de ce mouvement du
l'irak tout ça pour rien
non pas pour rien d'abord parce que ces
formateurs et puis c'est aussi la
démonstration à la face du monde qu une
contestation pacifique
de la politique qui est menée en algérie
depuis son indépendance est possible et
il est triste de constater que les
dirigeants algériens n'est pas saisi la
main tendue par la population pour avoir
une transition pour passer à une
transition en douceur une transition qui
aurait pu être négocié pourquoi ça n'a
pas été le cas est ce que les vieux
réflexes sont revenus
alors oui vous avez raison d'abord il ya
des vieux réflexes et puis il ya aussi
le fait qu'on constate aujourd'hui avec
un petit peu de recul
que les dirigeants algériens sont
divisés entre à la fois sur l'attitude à
adopter mais également sur le fait qu'il
n'a plus de projet et ne savent plus
comment sur le plan diplomatique c'est
l'air extérieur comment l'algérie doit
se situer mais également sur le plan
interne ils n'ont plus de projet si ce
n'est la répression à laquelle nous
assistons depuis maintenant presque cinq
ans évidemment il y avait trois ans de
lutte mais a eu aussi une crise
sanitaire a est ce que ça a fait taire
quelque peu aussi ce mouvement de façon
forcée
oui là aussi
là comme vide a été l'un des alliés
objectifs de ce régime
tout cela est quand même
là la démonstration encore une fois que
rien n'est réglé
en algérie on le voit dans la poursuite
de la répression aujourd'hui tous
azimuts pas seulement contre les
militants du frac mais contre toute
forme d'expression divergents et
également rien n'est réglé rien n'est
réglé c'est un pays qui part à la dérive
c'est un pays qui est en train de
s'effondrer et c'est un état qui est
aujourd'hui isolé sur le plan
diplomatique
que ce soit en interne puisqu'il est
contesté par une majorité de sa
population ou en externe quand on voit
les menaces à toutes ses frontières et
pour tenter de se former entre
guillemets le régime était aussi de la
chirurgie surenchère
diplomatiques notamment avec le voisin
de l'algérie et le maroc et on est
aujourd'hui dans une crise diplomatique
et politique que le pays n'a jamais
connu depuis son indépendance
indépendance qu'il va qui va être
commémoré pour les 60 ans dans quelques
dans quelques jours et ce sera un triste
bilan malheureusement 300 personnes
environ qui sont emprisonnés aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'algériens aussi qu'ils ont
décidé de quitter le pays c'est une
réalité
oui alors ça c'est terrible
c'est terrible parce que cela va créer
je dirais dans la pyramide de la
constitution d'un état un trou parce que
il faut des années pour former des bons
techniciens des ingénieurs des cartes
bref tout ce qui compose l'élite d'une
nation et tout ce qui permet un état de
fonctionner de manière à la fois
rationnelle et efficace et quand on voit
que des milliers d'algériens qui le
peuvent pas alors cela fait
effectivement un trou et cela va
provoquer dans les années qui viennent
on va le sentir on va le sentir à partir
des années 2018 2019 on va voir que
l'algérie va être confronté un manque le
cadre un manque de technicité dans un
monde dans une situation où aujourd'hui
nous vivons des révolutions
technologiques
successives pour lesquelles
jerry me semble pas être on prête merci
beaucoup kader abderrahim d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france